Youth recruitment by terrorist groups is a
global challenge.
This is particularly true in countries with
a youth bulge—where there is a disproportionate
number of individuals under the age of 30.
Many such countries have already seen significant
terrorist activity, including Afghanistan,
Nigeria, and Yemen.
The United States needs a better response.
U.S. efforts thus far have focused on countering
terrorists’ propaganda, primarily via the
internet.
This only addresses one part of the problem.
3% of surveyed violent extremists in Africa
reported joining a group through internet
contacts.
Roughly 60% joined through a friend or family
member.
The United States must shift its counterterrorism
resources accordingly.
Families should be seen for what they are:
a social network that can both impede
or facilitate the spread of violent extremism.
Targeted and tailored outreach programs should
engage with high-risk families to counter
terrorists’ exploitation of youth, because
children’s lives are on the line.
Should countering youth radicalization be a part of US counter-terrorism strategy?
Let us know in our poll.
Also let us know what other topics you'd like
our scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be
sure to like and subscribe for more research
and videos from AEI.